if you want to have freedom in your life
the way to get to freedom is is through
discipline
I'm gonna give you Mark Cuban rule
number one and whenever you forget this
rule you're already out of business
whether it was Steve Jobs about to give
one of his famous keynotes the most
underrated skill was this what's that
belief nation it's Evan I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
today let's live your best believed life
and learn the six skills that you
absolutely must master in order to
become successful also if you want to
know what Jocko would like Mark Cuban
Elon Musk and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
to join is in the description below
people want to know how to stop the
laziness and they want to know how to
stop the procrastination I've always
been passionate some people thought you
know it's a it's more OCD than anything
else there are times when something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do you do it in spite of fear
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with skill number
one get disciplined with Jocko willing
we all want freedom right we all want to
have freedom we want we want to have
financial freedom we want to have more
free time we don't have physical freedom
that's what we want
everyone wants freedom of course but if
you want to have freedom in your life
the way to get to freedom is is through
discipline it's that's how you get there
so if you want to be if you want to be
financially free you have to have
financial discipline you have to save
your money you have to work hard to earn
more money you have to not buy by stupid
things that you don't actually need
right you need to save that money and
invest it properly all that takes
discipline and if you have that kind of
discipline you'll end up with more
freedom if you want to be if you wanna
have more free time everybody wants more
free time but if you want more free time
how are you gonna get it you have to
have more discipline time management
skill number to push yourself with Dan
Locke I believe the number one habit you
need to develop to be successful it's on
a consistent if not a daily basis do
things that make you feel uncomfortable
it is that simple
because you look at what holds most
people back what holds you back is fear
fear of the unknown fear of failure fear
of rejection fear of success all these
things is all outside their comfort zone
human being because we're creature of
habits we tend to operate day to day and
do the same thing again and again and
again but if you have a habit to make a
habit that you do things on a consistent
basis that you don't usually do it makes
you scare it scare stuff out of you it
makes you stretch your comfort zone
that's how you gradually expand it and
get more of what you want maybe is going
to the event that you've never been to
maybe is meeting their successful people
that in that intimidates you maybe is
reading a book that you have no interest
reading in maybe it's driving a
different path that you usually call
home this way hey you know what I'm
gonna drive a different path and see
something a little bit different right
maybe it's watching a video that you
don't usually watch
maybe interested certain topics maybe
you're watching a YouTube video just on
prank but something you watch something
that is on inspiration and motivational
that's practical that's business-related
and that changes the way that you think
about stuff it started with that one
thing that one video and if you do that
not one time not two times not three
times but hundreds and hundreds of times
on a consistent basis I believe that is
the habit not just to be successful but
to stay successful when you're
constantly pushing yourselves outside of
the comfort zone guess what you will
learn
you will take new action you acquired
new knowledge you will meet new people
and that will lead to new opportunities
you might develop a new skill right
you might start a new business all these
things that you do is nothing more than
doing things that scares the [ __ ] out of
you
on a consistent basis instead of
avoiding the fear you are facing the
fear and you are pushing and pushing and
pushing a limit that is the number one
thing that you need I strongly believe
to be successful so developed a habit
today do something that you don't
usually do do something that scares you
do something that makes you
uncomfortable skill number three learn
how to sell with Mark Cuban
I'm gonna give you Mark Cuban rule
number one and whenever you forget this
rule you're already out of business in
every business sales Cure's all has
anybody ever heard of a business that
had zero sales sales that was successful
doesn't happen yet a lot of people start
their business thinking I have a great
idea I'm gonna do this this is amazing
I'm gonna go raise money I just sold
this idea and then it comes back and
it's like okay you got to sell that
product or you got to sell that service
that's the first and main key to a
successful business when you're getting
ready to start you have to answer that
question skill number four don't fear
fear with Elon Musk
what motivations that people need to
harness to try to make change as opposed
to just reading
about change that's not supposed to be
an easy question oh it's it's this well
like I said I think if you if you study
engineering and you figure out how to
design new things then it's relatively
easy to start a company you just need to
get a few like-minded people with you
and and then focus on creating a
prototype for compelling prototype as
soon as possible and then that you know
there's there's a strong venture capital
industry in this in this country that
will give you funding to take things to
the next level and that that's all
there's to it and you might you know try
it a few times might may or may not
succeed but I think sometimes people
fear fear starting a company too much
you know they have to say really what's
the worst that could go wrong you know
kind of stof to death you know you're
not gonna die of exposure what's worse
they could go wrong skill number five
develop your communication skills with
Jordan B Peterson I'm incredibly nervous
to talk in front of you because you've
got to be one of the most formidable
people that I've ever heard up or ever
listened to her ever seen so my question
is again you're one of the best
communicators that I've ever listened to
if I could be half as good at you or at
communicating as you are I would be set
how can I teach myself to do that
practice you know really like well
there's a couple of things is helps to
read a lot it really helps to write so
if you want to make yourself articulate
which is a very good idea then not only
should you read but you should write
down what you think and if you can do
that a little bit every day 15 minutes
maybe you could steal fifteen minutes
and do it every day but if you do that
for ten years you really straighten out
your thinking if you're gonna speak
effectively you have to know way more
than you're talking about you know so if
you this is often difficult for
beginning lectures at university because
they'll do a lecture on the top
but they only know as much as they're
saying in the lecture and they get kind
of stuck to their notes because of it
but you want to know ten times as much
as you are saying in the lecture and
then you can specify a stepping path
through it and elaborate with the other
things that you know but to do that you
have to do a lot of reading but you also
have to do a lot of reading because
that's where the synthesize that's where
the synthesizing comes so that's on the
input side and then on the output side
well there's some tricks techniques
let's say is like if you're speaking in
front of a group you are not delivering
a talk to a group that's not what you're
doing the talk isn't a package thing
that you present to a group there isn't
a group there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when I talk to a
group I always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier to because
you know how to talk to a person it's
like can you talk to a thousand people
well probably not because it's too
intimidating but there isn't a thousand
people there there's a thousand
individuals and so you just look at an
individual and you say something and you
can tell if they're engaged they look
confused or they look interested or they
look angry or they look bored or maybe
they're asleep in which case you look at
someone else and they give you feedback
about how you're doing and so one thing
is to to have something to say yeah but
the next thing is pay attention to who
you're talking to
because unless you're very badly
socialized and that seems unlikely in
your case because you know you present
yourself at least moderately well you
know and well I mean I don't know you
very well but at first but on first
sight you know you're doing fine so the
probability that if you pay attention to
the individuals that you're talking to
that your natural wealth of social skill
will manifest itself is extremely high
and so you don't deliver a talk to an
audience that's a really bad way of
thinking about you're actually engaged
in a conversation with an audience even
if they're not talking they're nodding
and shifting position and you know
looking like this or and you can you can
pull all that in and
and use it to govern the level at which
you're addressing the entire audience so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could bunch of that to some degree well
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent in everything you do then
to learn how to communicate I don't care
if you're gonna be a carpenter I mean
being a carpenter by the way is very
difficult especially if you're a good
carpenter but if you're good at
communicating as a carpenter you're like
ten times better as a carpenter so the
and this is something that the liberal
arts colleges I think and I don't know
if they've forgotten it but they don't
do a very good job of marketing it's
like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree in Bachelor of Arts it's like
well you can think you can write you can
speak you've read something it's like
the economic value that is incalculable
the people that I've watched in my life
would be spectacular ly successful or
they have skills clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful well that's
kind of like the definition of success
in life right you negotiate and you're
six it doesn't mean you win because if
you're a good negotiator if you're
really good negotiator everybody walks
away from the negotiation thrilled and
so then people line up to do things with
you so and that's all that's all
dependent on your ability to communicate
so practice and skill number six the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is visualize with jay Shetty
whether it's David Beckham taking one of
his famous free kicks whether it's Lewis
Hamilton winning the formula one whether
it was Steve Jobs about to give one of
his famous keynotes the most underrated
skill
visualization the recreation of images
sounds and environments before it has
happened is one of the most powerful
skills in the world a very powerful
meditation and mindfulness practice
visualization has been used for
centuries to help prepare the mind the
body and the consciousness for upcoming
challenges situations and circumstances
some of the world's greatest athletes
use visualization as a way to prepare
for big games the big day musicians for
their new concerts and tours and CEOs
for their very important meetings
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Tony Robbins on how to master the
skill of influence that I think you're
gonna really enjoy but before that it's
time for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your business or your
life and if you're feeling bold leave
your replies in the comments below here
we go question number one which of these
six skills do you need to improve first
number two what are you afraid of that
is preventing you from getting started
and number three how will you push
through that fear
I believe that leadership is really a
skill of influence is the most important
skill that any human being can master
and I don't think of leadership as a
position I see it as a skill a tool that
all of us have to have in other words
the quality of your life either really
believe comes down to your level of
leadership other people don't have to
follow you to be a leader but you have
to live life on your terms and the first
person you have to influence it yourself
you know whether you're fit or fat you
know whether your kids are out you know
on drugs or not it's who has more
influence the guy in the street corner
or you with your fitter fat is can you
influence your own hands your own body
your own mind to do what's necessary so
I think to be able to influence the
thoughts the feelings the emotions and
the actions of another human being
that's what leadership is raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that that people passion and
not one drop of myself work depends on
Europe it's suppose to mean
if you like this video check out the 20
pieces of advice every aspiring
entrepreneur needs to hear video it's
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there and to work on the
alignment of your personality